estas imágenes han circulado en redes
sociales y prensa local son cinco
presuntos miembros del grupo escorpión
del Cartel del Golfo maniatados fueron
entregados con una nota de Disculpa
serían los artífices del secuestro de
cuatro estadounidenses y el asesinato de
dos de ellos esta semana en Matamoros en
el estado de Tamaulipas las víctimas
fueron repatriadas mientras las familias
todavía no se creen lo ocurrido es una
locura ver a tu propio hijo arrebatado
de ti de esa manera atado a una cama de
forma violenta y no se lo merecía por lo
que era Era un amor tenía un gran
corazón
en este último país el miércoles los
republicanos presentaron dos proyectos
de ley para considerar a los carteles
como grupos terroristas y autorizar al
ejército estadounidense a combatirlos
López Obrador respondió con contundencia
nosotros no vamos a permitir
ningún gobierno extranjero Y mucho menos
que intervengan fuerzas armadas
de un gobierno extranjero en nuestro
territorio
sin embargo entre víctimas mexicanas hay
de sazón en tan solo cuatro días se
resolvió la situación de los
estadounidenses mientras el país tiene
más de 100.000 desaparecidos aparte de
la ciudadanía americana qué más tenían
estos americanos que el gobierno de los
Estados Unidos estaba tan interesado en
recuperarlos o fue por el video tan
mediático que se subió a las redes
sociales y que exhibió la forma tan
impune en que se llevan a la gente en
México porque eso que se ve en los
videos pasa todos los días casi este
jueves además se produjo una reunión
entre el gobierno de México y Elizabeth
ser guth Randall asesora de seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos un
intercambio para luchar contra el
tráfico de drogas con la preocupación
del fentanilo y el tráfico de armas